[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
happy happy tuesday everyone it's also
emily compagno's birthday
i wonder how she's going to celebrate it
yeah you probably don't remember that
from last year huh
so glad i kept the tape
all right welcome to the decade of lower
expectations where joe biden hears
applause when he makes it through lunch
without leaving his teeth stuck in a
sandwich
low expectations it's the new black
first there's san francisco where the
city paper asks earnestly should
residents and businesses tolerate
burglaries as part of a city part of a
city living in focus instead on
barricading homes it's a fair question
the thing about burglars they're
probably just looking for bread
as aoc once said about hordes of
organized retail looters you remember
the riots right hundreds of looters
running out of stores with loaves of
sourdough in boxes
that for some reason had nike logos on
them
maybe that's why car theft is soaring in
san francisco there might be bread in
there
that's why murder is way uh people are
foolishly defending bread
oh
and if you can't tolerate that maybe
it's you who's the problem
what do you have against theft do you
have property privilege don't you see
that you having that wallet lords over
that man with the knife who doesn't have
a wallet
but i guess that's what they mean by
reimagining public safety criminals
don't rob people
people have stuff that needs robbing
meanwhile the media has taken the low
expectation bar to a new low
they point out that rising inflation is
really a good thing so get used to it
it's the exact thing i used to tell
myself back in college when the rash
kept returning
msnbc tried vainly to explain why
inflation is a good thing but less
people bought it than tickets to see the
movie cats
they explain that americans can only pay
more for heating oil gas and food if
they first of course have more money
except all that printed money makes it
worth less requiring you to spend more
of it for the same stuff
the argument that americans are buying
more because they have more is just like
biden claiming 3.5 trillion costs zero
it doesn't add up
uh if only the price of peanut butter
was as low as his iq
cheap shot and now heating costs unlike
joe's approval ratings are expected to
skyrocket his own energy secretary
warned that americans will have to pay
more to heat their homes this winter
so what does joe do
closes more pipelines because that
worked with the keystone right slapping
restrictions on fracking didn't help
either energy independence is now as
over as mayor pete's paternity leave
thank god he lost the baby weight
so even amid a global energy crisis they
want to shut down the l5 pipeline from
michigan to canada and when they told
the prez about the l5 he just yelled
bingo he's more out of loop than cat at
a convent
i don't know what that means so why does
joe biden close pipelines
because they give you gas
is his problem not ours
really the only pipeline he should be
shutting is the one that runs from his
stomach to his ass
talk about lower expectations more like
lower intestinal expectations
you know it's bad when the british
royals only take away from that climate
meeting was that joe's farts were the
longest heard in recorded history
and louder than the maiden flight of the
concorde
the duke of windsor more like breaking
windsor
camilla parker bowles more like joe
biden's bowels
eric swalwell must be green with envy
or broccoli either way he needs to up
his fiber intake because while joe may
not outsmart you he will outfart you
what's happening to me
i really do think the intervention you
held for me really paid off i feel
almost like a new man it's kind of
oh you got to be kidding me
this is another intervention
yes
i stopped with the poop jokes
it's not the poop jokes it's the fart
jokes today
but i stopped the poop jokes what do you
got to get fart jokes what did eric
swalwell do to deserve this besides you
know ah blow it out your ass
that's what we're talking about shut up
two interventions in two days i'm
breaking cap's record
so we went from peace in the middle east
relaxed tensions in north korea
operation warp speed all from trump to
this a man who passes the buck
as much as he passes the wind
sorry
and look at the media you want low
expectations cnn happily defends joe
saying there's nothing he could do to
reduce and reduce the energy prices yeah
because increasing drilling and not
blocking pipelines just isn't possible
but cnn they have a lot on their plate
their two prime time hosts are currently
accused of various things from groping
to even more groping but maybe they're
hard of hearing when their boss said all
hands on deck
they heard all hands on
you know the rest
so why are the median politicians
embracing low expectations well it takes
the pressure off them to do the actual
work the politicians don't have to solve
the problems and the hacks at cnn don't
have to call them on it for not solving
the problems just get the american
people to accept failure and we could
all put it on cruise control but more
important while you're expected to lower
expectations they don't
they can afford any hardship to fund the
police no problem they got hired
security they're closing the nearby
walgreens cool my assistant picks up the
generic viagra for me
that was just
an example
gas costs more my driver jeeves takes
care of that after he rubs my feet and
jelly
so let him eat cake until the price of
milk eggs and sugar makes that no longer
possible because more people needing
handouts means more potential democrat
votes but even biden's chief of staff
admits things are looking bad i wonder
if ron klain thinks it's been a rough
and tough year
it's been a rough and tough year and we
knew it would be president biden said
this all the time we're in a year-long
effort to dig out of the holes we were
left
yeah the holes they're digging out of
holes no they just dug them deeper and
where there weren't any holes like the
energy sector they went out and they dug
new ones
and that's the scam run the country into
the ground even under the ground because
they're not affected by it it's all on
you and you better suck it up unless in
a year you go to the polls and treat
them all like dirt
joining me now to discuss the current
state of the biden administration the
president's chief of staff ron klain
hello mr claim hello
first off welcome to the show i want to
get right to it uh both gas and
electricity prices and rent are really
high what's what's the administration's
plan to get them down do you have any
well gas isn't high if you have an
electric car and if electricity is
included in your rent that's no problem
and rent's not a problem either if you
own your own mansion like i do
you seem to have all the answers for
yourself uh but it also sounds like your
glass is always half full kind of guy
actually greg i'm a hat glass half empty
kind of guy glass half full is
pessimistic because it's better if you
have less for instance no one ever said
i wish i had more diarrhea unless it's
unless it's you writing your monologue
jokes
that wasn't necessary and it also
doesn't make any sense
you're wrong greg it makes perfect sense
it life depends on your outlook you
could be sitting in a beautiful mansion
you own and think this sucks or you
could be constantly struggling to
survive and say to yourself cool it's
like i'm job from the bible
so next time you go to the grocery store
and you see empty shelves instead of
complaining just thank your lucky stars
we're blessed with so many shelves
wow ron this has been eye-opening
thanks for having me greg
thank you the president's chief of staff
ron plain everyone
now
let's welcome tonight's guest
she knows how to approach the bench then
cartwheel over it outnumbered cohost
emily compagno
he's so bright he has to turn himself
off in the movie theater former white
house national security council aide
pass patel
she's like a spider web skinny white and
full of dead insect parkinson's
fox's contributor pat tim
and the tower of pisa was fine until he
leaned on it my massive sidekick in the
nwa's world television champion tyrus
emily happy birthday oh thanks you got
any plans tonight
this this is great oh that's good
excellent yeah because it's very late
right now you're not going to go out
after this show it'll be like midnight
straight to bed straight to bed like you
always do
up at the crack of dawn yep good for you
psychopath
um
is it i mean isn't it kind of a terrible
strategy to force americans to think
about the upside of inflation rather
than try to treat it absolutely what do
our tax dollars pay for that's what i
want to know let's take san francisco so
it's one of the most expensive cities in
the world to live in it's why black and
brown communities have been pushed out
of it it's why people pay taxes property
taxes alone in the millions simply to
exist there and yet now they're being
told that what their tax dollars do is
pay for nothing because they should just
barricade themselves in there and then
part of the argument by the mainstream
media for inflation was well coming out
of 2020 americans were the quote richest
they've ever been well on the backs of
what administration was that exactly
because the second this administration
took the helm things turned
yeah and in terms of these the tax
situation and the inflation that this
administration and all of its elitism
its tone deafness
its refusal to connect with ordinary
real americans the price of children's
shoes is up the highest it's ever been
don't i know
[Music]
since they started keeping records there
you go yeah furniture heating the home
up 700 uh dollars estimated this this
season these are things that everyone
has to deal with that affects every
single ordinary american except for the
people in this administration that
continue to tell us that we are the
enemy we should just shut up and take it
and yet keep paying more taxes to pay
for these crime-ridden neighborhoods
that don't protect us and just i know
people laugh but like there is a
strategy to buying children's shoes
because they're cheaper even at the same
size than the adult shoes that's why i
shop at gap for kids
that's true that's yeah cash you know
what i find really funny about this
whole thing that i also shop at gaffer
kids
that jacket
i've seen that before it's extra large
oh there you go see what i mean you know
what's weird is that though the left
creates the policies that then
they beg you to lower your expectations
for the perfect example is we're for
defunding the police but now you have to
barricade yourself so it's like now up
to you to face the consequences of their
own policies well that's what they do i
mean minnesota is a perfect example
seattle whatever you want to talk about
it and i always go to gated communities
it's kind of the perfect example so many
on the left live in these gated
communities up on the hills in these
vaunted palaces and until the crime
actually hits them yeah then when it
does hit them they say donald trump you
screwed up we're getting attacked and we
have to actually put criminals in jail
but again
the left continues to put criminals in
jail lets them out the next day and then
they go out and rape old uh women which
is totally tragic and it happens monthly
not to mention two year olds getting
shot in chicago yeah but i'm sure that's
trump's fault yeah there you go you know
tyrus they are counting on our own
sophistication to understand what
they're doing isn't that true they
assume we're all really dumb right if
they can tell if somebody's trying to
tell you inflation is a good thing
they're calling you an idiot
well you know what greg i kind of got to
disagree with you they didn't ask yeah
they're not having the conversation
they're not saying hey i'd like to have
your thoughts oh i already know
i got you yeah less police
more
funding things for me and my friends and
you guys will just kind of figure it out
they didn't ask anyone they have you you
yet well i mean the poor fella can't ask
a question anyway we literally saw that
he tried to ask a hypothetical and we
ended up on episode of gilligan's island
we just never know where this guy's
gonna go but unfortunately the ones who
do know
they're perfectly fine with it because
in a way this is their way of
retribution you had four years where you
kind of did what you wanted and you said
what you wanted and you went out and you
capitalized on capitalism and you opened
businesses oh not on our watch it's not
going to happen we're taking all that
away and we're all going to share
everything except our stuff exactly and
the reason why they're doing that cat is
to make the population more dependent on
the government they were less dependent
on the government under trump now they
have no choice because everything's
expensive and you get the free money
there and that creates yeah unless you
don't want your house to be broken into
yes that's true then you're all on your
own
it's remember these are the same people
who years ago were saying remember the
victim blaming thing like if you said
hey like you know you know maybe you
know women you shouldn't walk around in
this park peop you know alone at night
that was victim blaming but now if
you're like my house is burglarized like
yeah were you barricading yourself
inside of it yes as if it were a zombie
apocalypse because maybe you should have
done that yeah that's on them it doesn't
make you know that's like i want the
government to do very little as a
libertarian i want them to do absolutely
nothing almost except for like keep
people from stealing my stuff and keep
people from killing people and raping
people and that's the part where they're
deciding to slack exactly
and it's all this other extraneous stuff
that they're they're they're clinging to
make sure you're two-year-old as a
mascot i know
they're iding children yeah iding
children for certain indoor activities
well i'm often mistaken
but like you know you can't you can't
ask for an id anywhere else you can't
get a homeless guy off your porch you
can't do anything like that but they're
gonna they're gonna um force a kid to
have us have his papers
right
the papers for kids are only for potty
training
i don't know what that means hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else